really this should be called a toss fry
more than a stir-fry stir-fry is a sort
of misnomer for it in a wok fire oil and
metal combine in an explosive chemical
reaction to create stir-fry when you
order it at the restaurant even at the
cheapest hole in the wall place the meat
comes out super tender everything has a
really nice savory intense flavor to it
but is that taste due to extreme
temperatures perhaps some secret alloy
wok we asked chef and food science
writer kenji lopez alt why does
restaurant-style stir-fry just hit
different some of it involves the way
we're going to treat the meat before we
cook it and then some of it involves the
way we transfer heat to the food during
the actual cooking process
let's cook alongside the guy who
literally wrote the book on walks and
explore the science behind perfect stir
fry
the important part of a stir-fry have
everything ready before you start
cooking our experiment needs protein
alkalines vegetable aromatics sauce
thickener oil and of course a very hot
walk
i'm using a carbon steel wok carbon
steel is what i recommend people use at
home carbon steel gets this layer of
what's called black oxide when you heat
it up so that's what makes the steel all
black that black oxide not only aids in
sort of giving it non-stick properties
but more importantly it actually
transfers flavor to your food so if you
were to cook a stir fry in a carbon
steel seasoned wok like this versus a
stainless steel wok and feed them to
people side by side the difference in
flavor is really immediate and obvious
so i'm going to start by preheating my
wok on the highest heat the goal here is
to get the bottom of the wok really
really ripping hot there's this
expression that a hot wok and cold oil
prevents sticking i tested this a number
of times the temperature of the oil
actually doesn't matter that much but
what you do want to do is add the oil
right before adding your food the idea
is that when you get your wok hot enough
to the point that you're going to be
properly stir-frying that is going to be
well beyond the smoke point of an oil
even a sort of neutral so this is peanut
oil it has a very high smoke point it's
going to be getting up to around 600
degrees or so maybe even hotter that's
well beyond the smoke point of peanut
oil so if you leave the oil in there and
let it sit for too long before you start
cooking it's going to start developing
these really sort of acrid burnt flavors
so preheat your wok really well add your
oil and as soon as you add your oil
swirl it around and get your food in
there so that the oil doesn't get a
chance to burn
having the right walk technique is key
let's get a close-up look at the
mechanics of those moves so you might
notice that
this is called a stir fry
but i'm actually doing relatively little
stirring in fact some chefs don't even
like to use a spatula they'll just toss
like this so really this should be
called a toss fry more than a stir fry
so there's two motions in the walk
there's tilting and then there's
translational motion forward and back
and so what you're doing is the first
part you're tilting the walk forward and
it's back towards you then while it's
still tilted forward you're pushing it
translationally away from you and then
you're tilting it towards you and then
pulling it back towards you and that's
the basic motion and that's how you get
the food to kind of blow over itself in
a kind of ways
the rotational motion and rapid
translational acceleration will cause
the food to leap in the air until mostly
cooked through while becoming lightly
browned in spots so the hottest spot of
the walk is going to be this area down
here and you'll see as i'm tossing the
food that's actually where it spends the
most amount of time it heats up on the
bottom here through conduction with the
metal and then as you're tossing it
through the air you're really
encouraging the evaporation of moisture
from it that's what the whole tossing
motion is for
chinese kitchen burners are 20 times
hotter than home burners so what's the
at-home workaround to keep the meat
tender and the veggies crisp
so i'm cooking this stuff in approximate
half pound batches that is reasonable
for this kind of relatively high output
stove you know i lived in a new york
city apartment for a while that had a
really really crappy stove and when i
cooked there i found that if i tried to
do a half pound at a time things would
end up sort of stewing and simmering
instead of properly stir-frying so if
you're finding that your food is coming
out kind of wet or bubbly cook in even
smaller batches all right that broccoli
is done
one of the most crucial steps is adding
alkalinity to the beef so let's take a
step back and see the chemistry behind
the prep
[Applause]
the vast majority of the work you're
gonna do in a stir fry comes before you
actually put the pan on the heat the
most important parts are getting all of
your food into nice uniform pieces so
with meat you want to cut it into pieces
that go against the grain that are
relatively thin this will help them cook
really fast so now we're going to move
into washing the meat which is the part
where a lot of home cooks don't do this
but it is essential so what we're going
to do is put the meat into a bowl
and just cover it with cold water like
this and what you want to do is really
get in there and massage it
you know imagine that you're working
like a tight muscle that you really want
to relax because that's basically
exactly what you're doing you want to
squeeze out as much of the sort of red
pigment the myoglobin that's in them as
possible because what that's going to do
is allow room for marinades and sauces
to penetrate so your meat's going to
come out more flavorful you might think
yourself oh i'm just sticking my hand
into a bowl of blood this is not
actually blood in here this is the color
of myoglobin myoglobin is the pigment
inside muscles and used for similar
things in the body oxygen transport and
management but this is not actually
blood now we're going to put in a
strainer and we're going to give it a
really good squeeze
treat it like you're kind of wringing
out wet clothes
so the next step in the process is
marinating so i'm adding about a half
teaspoon of baking soda per pound of
beef baking soda it's alkaline so it has
a relatively high ph and what happens is
it prevents muscle proteins from
tightening up overly as they cook which
means that when your beef cooks it
doesn't expel as much moisture so it
stays juicier don't be afraid of
breaking it up there's really no way to
do this too vigorously all right so now
that we have the baking soda in there
i'm going to add the other marinade
ingredients so that's going to be a half
teaspoon of kosher salt and a half
teaspoon of light soy sauce now salt is
also important because what it does is
it breaks down some of the protein so
that they again they don't squeeze as
tightly soy sauce also contains enzymes
called proteases which actively break
down proteins and make them more tender
as well so we're going to do some
shushing wine
this is mainly for flavor
sesame oil and some sugar as well again
for flavor
and then finally a little bit of corn
starch as we mix it together and as we
marinate this meat the cornstarch is
going to form a sort of slurry that
coats the meat in a very very sort of
loose layer and what that does is that
any moisture that does get expelled from
the meat as it's stir-frying is going to
basically get caught up in that corn
starch slurry which is going to bind it
so it's going to help the meat retain
that moisture right next to it so it's
juicy as you bite into it all right so
we're just going to set this aside the
baking soda the salt and the soy sauce
they're going to continue to act and
they're going to make the meat more and
more tender so the longer you set it
aside the more tender the meat's going
to come out but you can get away with
about 15 minutes or so really the most
important thing with the meat is the
washing that's going to get you like 90
of the way to the tenderness
now the broccoli it's important that you
spread it out into a single layer like
this so that all the moisture has a
chance to evaporate when you're
stir-frying your main goal is to
evaporate moisture as fast as possible
the reason for this is that you want
your vegetables and your meat and
everything to stay bright and crunchy
and moisture is really the enemy of heat
it's a huge energy sink so the less
moisture you have on your food to the to
begin with the better it's going to cook
during the stir-fry evaporating moisture
is is the biggest energy consumption uh
when you're cooking food whether you're
searing a steak whether you're searing
chicken breasts whether you're
stir-frying so the drier you get your
food to start with
the better it's going to sear or the
better it's going to stir-fry
let's rewind to the prep and see a key
step that will lead to crunchy yet
cooked broccoli i've got this pot of
blanching water going so this is
basically just lightly salted water that
i've got at a full boil i like to do
this whenever i'm working with green
vegetables because it helps them it
helps make sure that they cook evenly
first of all but also gives them a
brighter green color so we get our
broccoli in there we're just going to
let it simmer
for less than a minute basically until
you see it turn really bright green
and we're going to take it right out
now we're going to stir fry it so again
a little bit of oil as soon as that oil
is in there we swirl it around and we're
going to get half of our broccoli in
[Music]
all right let's just get the broccoli
out of there
the final element in wake is has to do
with the way you add the sauce to it
chinese american food typically has a
lot more sauce than stir fries you would
find in china so the flavor profile in
here is mainly going to be umami salty
and sweet so the umami that's our
sensation of savoriness it's something
that we taste sort of in the back of our
mouths it makes us salivate the umami in
this comes from glutamic acid which
comes when you've long fermented sauces
that's the main part of msg what makes
msg taste so savory and the other thing
that's going to be in here is inocynic
acid which is something that we get out
of fish and shellfish so the oyster
sauce in here is going to be rich in
inocinic acid that acts basically as a
glutamic acid amplifier so when you have
them together they have this sort of
synergistic effect where one of them
helps the other and they make each other
stronger than either one of them would
be separately
so what do you think kenji can homemade
stir-fry compete with takeout it smells
really good it looks really good i think
i don't know if it's coming across on
camera but it looks great in person so
the secrets here the really important
part was the washing the meat and
marinating it with alkaline and then
finally making sure that everything was
in uniform sizes cooking in small
batches so that we don't overload our
wok and saucing at the very end so let's
see how it is
yup i mean
silky smooth incredibly tender meat
bright green broccoli
a nice savory sweet
umami
balanced flavor that's good
i'd eat it